[Music]
hi everyone this is Roman's Grandmaster
Sabina Fleischer I'm here at the San
Luis chess club and for today's lecture
we are going over the grandmaster's
choice which is gonna be my choice for
today and for today I chose Fighting
Chess I really enjoy a good
um attacking game and
um I've seen a couple of very
interesting games that are taking place
at the moment in the European Chess
Championship
and the first game that I want to show
you today and I want us to go over is a
game between Anton corabov and former
World Cup champion uh Ruslan ponomariov
and korob is known for his amazing I
think attacking style and he's played in
a lot of GCT
events and
um I really I really thought I really
thought this game was brilliant you know
so let's get started
so karma started with D4
and welcome everyone by the way if
you're watching us you know from home
from somewhere hi I hope you're doing
well
uh and welcome everyone who's here at
the club I hope you guys will enjoy this
game and hopefully you haven't seen it
so that we can learn some interesting
things
so korubov is a very strong Grandmaster
from Ukraine same as ponamario
and they played the
um basically this is this is on team
names of Indian right so if you play
Knight C3 in this position black
typically responds with Bishop B4
uh and then they're very smooth the
white can play in this position Queen C2
is one of them I used to play this so
many times when I was a kid it was one
of my pet lines I won so many games but
there are of course some other
variations that white can go for E3 is
one of the most played lines
uh and Knight F3 and A3 and pretty much
everything I think it's very important
when you're learning and opening
whether it is you know for white and
opening or for black a defense it's very
important to know the key squares and a
very important Square in the names of
Indian
is the E4 Square so
um here
the the purpose of Queen C2 is of course
to control the E4 Square so that we can
get to play E4 because we couldn't
currently of course because you know
we're being pinned so we would lose upon
but anyways Knight F3 was the choice of
of corabov because he wanted to
to play a system against the nimso and
now Knight C3 so we transposed basically
back to a Queen's Gambit for those of
you who maybe are new to chess or
interested in this and you don't know
what move orders are
you basically can get to the exact same
position if you were to play like this
so we have the exact same position
now
if black wanted to play just the normal
Queen's Gambit declined they could have
just continued with Bishop E7 but
ponomario chose the line with Bishop B4
uh which is also called the ragozen
defense and
um you know I was I was quite excited to
see this game because I often struggled
against aragos and I had a very painful
loss one time in the U.S
and the US Women's Championship and you
know Bishop G5 is kind of the most
played line and then when I saw this
game I was like hmm maybe I came up with
the new well I didn't come up I just saw
a new idea that's why you know it's
really cool to check top players games
because you end up you end up finding
new lines that maybe you weren't
familiar with or maybe you are
struggling with the one line and you
didn't know what to do and suddenly you
see an idea
uh that could become part of your
repertoire
so maybe for someone who's uh
a beginner let's say you're being told
not to take your queen out early but the
point of this move is
um of course it's a Czech Bishop but the
point is to get black to play Knight C6
with black you typically want to find a
way to push the C Pawn whether it is C6
or C5 you're on the pawn push so that
you're giving yourself a little bit more
space but in this position Queen A4 it
does take the queen out early but it
also forces the Knight to go to C6 and
because the Knight is there
um
it's the the Knight would have to move
eventually back so the pawn pushes and
yeah maybe White's Queen is kind of out
of play here but don't worry we will be
bringing it back into into play even
eventually
okay so white continues their
development now
E3 is the most natural uh move for white
Bishop G5 is another option
uh but but the reason we play E3 is to
make sure we're protecting this pawn and
so
we do with this C4 Pawn by opening the
bishop
Castle
Bishop D2 now white does not want to
allow the doubling
of the pawns here so if you were to take
obviously we would capture back with the
bishop
I see a lot of people in the chat are
saying hi I know a lot of them by their
username so thanks for stopping by
and here this was the move that I was
quite excited to see
so Bishop D6 C5
why is this important well typically you
see black returning with a bishop in E7
like this is uh this is something you
expect or capturing in C3 like I showed
you the point with Bishop D6 is to
actually attract C5 and you would think
with the black that this move is not
very good for white because
typically if you choose to blockade the
position in the center
you are giving black the option to push
later on E5 and kind of have a clear
attacking plan in the center and the
King side
so this is a move that I often tell my
students not to play whether it is in
the London system uh with black or
sometimes with white I tell them don't
play that unless you're sure you can
come up with a good plan to give yours
yourself more space
on the queen side like really and you
can actually open up the position
because otherwise black has a very
simple plan
but corable he played this move and um
he actually played it quite quite fast I
would say if you guys I believe it is
visible in in the video as well you see
he had like a minute third almost a
minute 32 and he got to 129cc he spent a
little bit of time in this and there
weren't so many games actually played in
this specific position
but he went for the move
and obviously when you go for such a
move again you need to make sure you
have a very clear plan of how to
continue
to push the pawns forward and
attack on the queen side
because otherwise black will prep to
play E5 E4 and start upon march on the
king side
okay
so
B4 let's go for the attack fighting
chest attacking chess I love this the
reason I love fighting just so much and
attack whether it like even if it's not
towards the king directly it's because
I don't think I played very well myself
like when I end up playing I'm more of a
positional player so every time I try to
push the pawns too much I end up just
you know messing up so it's always nice
to see other players do it maybe one day
I will learn it myself
and um
it's okay so 94 a very natural move to
kind of block all kind of ideas for why
to even consider to play for although
those wouldn't be very good clearly
white is going to push the pawns on the
green side
and um
and maybe getting some ideas with F5
does anyone in the audience and then of
course people can write in the chat as
well I'll check it no who kind of came
up with these ideas with the F Pawn push
it was Pillsbury Pillsbury kind of had
this idea actually I wrote an article
about it
um
last year
he came up with the idea but for white
to play F4 F5 and
um you you see this kind of approach
when the center is blocked you
it's fine for black to push the pawn and
it would be fine for white because there
would be no way for the king to be in
danger because the diagonal is locked
but you can use F5 F4 as a means to
attack
so white needs to rush in this position
so he went
for
he went for for uh B5 yes yes sir
sarawan a great commentator and this is
he's often here at the club often says
push push the pawns push them as much as
possible and however just keep in mind
once you push upon you can go back so
when you push them make sure you're not
leaving too much stuff behind too many
squares that you cannot control anymore
that could be utilized by your opponent
because then
you know
there's a trade-off
but here's the thing as soon as white
played B5
he kind of allowed
uh black to capturing D2
so
what's
what's going on I'm reading some of the
twitch I'm not reading sorry some of the
chat I'm not reading all of it because
then I'll definitely get distracted from
the game but I'm kind of picking
through it a little bit
so there's this idea for black snide to
capture the bishop in D2 should we worry
well we already pushed B5 so there's no
turning back so obviously he probably
thought about it when he played B5 but
now let's think about it ourselves
would it be okay would we be fine with
white if black were to capture our
Bishop in D2
alright some are saying that the bishop
is blocked by the pawns that is right
this bishop is quite restricted we have
a lot of Pawns
maybe I should choose another color
because that orange wasn't really
visible but the bishop is really blocked
so you are actually quite fine if black
who's moved this Knight already twice
would capture your Bishop because you
know the your Bishop doesn't do much so
you would have to find a way to actually
open up the position for this bishop to
do something
but uh but what to do because like after
B5 you have to go back Knight to B8 if
you're not going to take in D2 and then
Whites Whites follow-up would probably
be capturing here
and then maybe 95
and um
I think White's position is more than
more than comfortable like
then we would have you know the route
coming to be one the Knight can go to C4
in case it's going to be chased away
this bishop goes to E2 at some point you
can certainly consider you know to play
F3 and I know
um you might be worried because you
don't have a 19 F3 anymore but it's
perfectly fine for white to go Bishop E2
and Castle short and then consider F3
after you have castled this would give
you
it would bring your king to safety and
would give you activity uh an attack on
the
King side as well
someone was asking was asking to look at
probably Epson manco's game you're
saying I love this game so I'm looking
at this game for now hopefully you guys
enjoyed this game as well it was a great
win by coroboth who by the way is the
only player in the European Championship
to have five out of five pretty much
everyone
like first 10 boards or so I think there
was just another decisive result
everything everyone else kind of went
for draws so and these players are from
the same country I mean you know and
they played as teammates for Olympic for
the uh their Olympic team for for many
years so
I think it's kind of a great great fight
in a way
um
so he decided to take here first and the
question is how do we capture back we
got two options we got the Knight or the
king
what do we choose
yeah in the previous position there was
not so much the black would do
bad Bishops support good Pawns
uh that's right that could be that could
be a thing for sure
in the audience here in the club does
anyone want to take a choice
with the Knight
what do you think
same
yeah so normally normally we would
capture with the Knight of course
because you know it's it's you know our
King we want to Castle right and then
Bishop D3
uh and then castle of course
uh but
okay this would be definitely a
continuation here here and then I feel
that black should kind of give himself a
little bit of space on the queen side
um and then we'll probably Castle
and uh maybe they try to do something
like this so they trade that their bad
bishop and the position is quite
balanced the interesting thing in this
game is that Coral both did not capture
with the Knight
had to come up with something something
cool so he captured with the King and he
captured quite fast look at that he
almost didn't think at all in this
position he just captured and
um
yeah it's my choice today I'm sorry guys
it's my choice so this was my choice
maybe maybe one day it would be the the
chat's choice or
um you know I think tomorrow I actually
am doing game analysis so if you guys
have games that would be your choice you
can give me your games and then I'll you
know you will be choosing what's
happening in the in the class
okay so King takes Z2 what king in the
center why is this okay because the
position is blocked this move is not
possible Right now the Knight is hanging
so he has to move them the Knight back
and now white basically has the same
position just he doesn't need to Castle
because he plays Bishop D3 and suddenly
white has completed development the two
Rooks are connected
and uh he can choose actually which side
of the board he wants his King to go to
if he feels that the center gets open
maybe he's gonna go to C2 if not maybe
he will shift on the other side so it's
kind of it's kind of cool it's I think
this move is really cool and nobody at
least leeches
um had no games I haven't had the chance
to check the database to see if there
were any other games if any of you have
the chance to do that please do so but
um
but there are no games he just went King
takes D2
okay
black is trying to give himself some
space now we have to talk about plants
because
black is struggling with the space so he
does want to play something like Bishop
D7 and try to trade as I showed you
previously
this move would be great as well but he
has to support it with F6 and even so
it's not
a move that black might be ready to play
um so he started with C6 first Rook B1
and uh C takes B5
why not B6 here after C6 someone is
asking me great question
great question
why do you think we don't play this
after this wise position is really
really bad because when when you realize
that you have more space on one side of
the board so in this case right the the
board cuts off in the middle and we
definitely have the response blocked
here so this is the difference this Pawn
in C5 versus this Pawn in C6 so when you
have more space on one side of the board
and your pawns also kind of point out
towards that direction
that is the side of the board where you
want to play what does that mean you
want to find a way to push the pawns
forward trade them off with the
opponent's pawns so that you open up
files for your pieces to get into play
because you don't have other way to
enter in your opponent's territory
for them they have to play on the other
side so if you're gonna play B6 you're
basically kind of
cutting off a lot of your resources to
open up a file
you want to take here eventually but
you're not going to take it right now if
you take too soon you're helping your
opponent how well he wants to get with
that Knight back out so he's just gonna
capture with the Knight his Knight is
back out and
um developed nobody gets to chase him
ever again and yes you open up the B
file but that pawn is easily protected
by black with robiative in Queen C7 he
can protect it he's got his Knight back
and he's happy so before you're going to
take you will make sure to place your
pieces on on much better positions on
the best possible positions you can so
that when you take you're actually
opening up your pieces
so with Basics yes
so now it's black to move so let's say
black would just develop so you would
take right
so now when you take here you're still
stuck like your blog this Pawn
um you can't you can't promote it you're
you're stuck there whenever you want to
support that pawn in any way you would
have to get the Knight like this right
for that to happen the queen has to move
so that's the the moment he will take
but right now the pawn is not dangerous
because it's blocked and you cannot get
black stroke away from there which means
that black and focus uh in the center
and
I don't know if he needs F6 he might be
able to just play E5 directly
and since you got the king in the center
he's trying to break your chain
now obviously he has this thread as well
Fork so
you either are going to move one of
these two pieces
because taking
he is just very happy right to take
stakes and then he takes
and
that pawn will fall it's like a lonely
Pawn it's not protected anymore and if
the Rook wasn't in A8 of course you
should you should take and try to
promote it this kind of situation also
happens sometimes on the king side
because
um like oftentimes people allow a pawn
to go all the way to H7 and then they
just go King h8 maybe you've seen
something like that before
so when that happens it's really sad for
white because they cannot just bring
their king sorry their Queen to capture
their own Pawn to mate so you're just
stuck your own Pawn is actually
stopping your fight and your attack so
that's that's the problem you win upon
but it's not a valuable one it's not one
you can actually utilize
does it make sense okay
um
so
oh someone was saying something fun
actually in this position okay it's
actually a good point I need to show
this so what about if Queen takes right
this is this is a fun thing that you can
say wait I take with the queen and then
when you take back I take with the pawn
and I'm promoting oh my God what are we
gonna do the bishop is is locked we
can't do anything
well obviously we can what's the move
camera
what is it
okay so which piece can stop the pawn
from promoting
the Knight could but that we would be
very happy if the night goes there we
take it and then we okay fine I mean you
go there but we will still be doing
really well here
it's kind of crazy but white would be
doing really well there
yeah the queen can go here and stop the
pawn
um kind of uh backwards Vision that's
it's nice to have and oftentimes we just
look forward we're so tempted to go and
attack that we forget that we have to
sometimes Retreat and this is kind of
okay just a forward move but with the
idea of retreating
um so I think here this position
even this position I think white is fine
white would be fine here even if they
don't promote too soon because black
would have to stay with one piece to
stop that pawn and there would also be
ideas possibly with some Bishop A6 at
some point in an end game and then push
this and then would have two pawns one
of those would would promote yeah black
is a queen up but but I think after
either this Rook or this Rook we either
go Bishop some Bishop A6 or we can push
this and I will have to connect it and
black doesn't have sufficient time most
likely to open up
but anyways let's go back to our game so
we want to put more pressure before we
choose to open up that side of the board
so here Rook a B1 C takes B5
and in this position korob decided to
capture with the bishop I like this this
move uh with the Knight ideal layer
would be nice to capture but I think
there's no I mean you attack that pawn
but you won't be taking it to remain
pinned
96 is anyway something that black wants
to do so I think his his choice Bishop
takes B5 is fine
and
Queen C7
I think this was probably a move a very
natural move that black might have
considered but unfortunately this move
does not work because we can just
capture and if you capture with the
queen of course we can just trade Queens
first and then take him B7 and oops
and white is just crushing here
extra pawn and everything so black wants
to develop but he cannot
so
I think
um I always recommend I know some people
don't in these days you know everyone
has their own kind of way of teaching
and describing things but I think it is
very very important that you
um spend the time to study the classics
and and see some of these games where
um some players were able to Super to
really dominate their opponents and
their you know world champions playing
against another world champion and they
just sometimes just had these one two
mistakes where they left pieces behind
um or they thought they have sufficient
time to do something and then
um because they stayed behind with the
development the other side the other
world champion uh really took advantage
of this so many games that I can think
of right now classical games that
something like that was happening but
okay this position is not a lot for
black or anything he's just needs to
find the right way to develop his pieces
without dropping material
and and going back just for one second
in case I haven't
explained it very well at first
the reason black chose to take he
doesn't want to normally he really wants
to support E5 but he cannot develop
otherwise he's really struggling he's
got no place to develop his pieces like
97 just drops this Pawn for free
Bishop D7 allows I think 95 or maybe
or yeah I think 95 is fine and then we
take that one is going to be hanging
because he cannot take his pieces out
he's just trying to give himself some
some air to breathe and that's why he
captures that that way
oh someone from Charlotte Center hi
there thanks for joining our stream
all right so finally black is playing F6
he really wants to support to find a way
to push the spawn forward
Bishop D7 again was a move that he
probably wanted to do but there's this
annoying 95 and the reason why it plays
this now is he's trying to keep the
position a little bit locked
um and he might want to play F4 and
what do you do now let's say you play
Knight C6
I think probably we can go F4 here or
like this seems like a like a nice nice
idea and even if black
gets to capture everything
probably I'm not sure which one which
piece probably Knight takes this bishop
even if it's the good Bishop considering
the remaining pawns that are blocked are
on the opposite color
it doesn't do so much this bishop this
Knight Will SL it will be slightly
better and I don't think we'll put it in
D6 so we might end up going back and
kind of doubling on the B file putting
pressure
and we might eventually
even maybe get our Knight to the side of
the board
maybe play
it depends what black will play it's
definitely another game here but
um but I think white has a superior
position due to a much better Knight and
sighting more space
so black is trying to push to find a way
to push E5
okay this bishop doesn't do much in B5
so he's back to D3
Knight C6
and the queen in A4 did its job the
point was right earlier in the game to
attract the Knight to go to C6 so the
black remained with the pawning C7 but
now he can just go back so he went back
to C2
switching a little bit and looking a
little bit on the king side and try to
attract black to make a pawn push to
weaken his King
because black has a pawn in F6 instead
of the Knight
he's really not going to be very happy
to push ups sorry to push G6 or H6
because the light squares would be very
weak G6 also would would allow at some
point some sacrifice in G6 so he chose
to play F5 but this move is another Palm
push what did they say earlier push the
pawns but think about what squares
you're giving to the opponent and
whether they will be able to take
advantage of them Now by pushing F5 you
are indeed blocking this Bishop from
looking to it to H7 but you're giving
this Outpost away
um and here you know with white what do
you think would be a good plan for white
in this position
like what what should why do the black
kind of blocked things definite D5 is
going to be tough to play now because
that pawn might be hanging this Pawn
might stay weak so what should white do
here
okay
I think normally this King does not
belong there at this point it doesn't
belong there anymore so you would love
if you could just suddenly just make
this move just bring your king to safety
first and then you know do something
uh on YouTube Chris is saying 91 player
four
and then Knight back to F3 okay I mean
that's an option I guess
um but why would you do that like you
know why why would you want to do that
though
foreign
it's
oh I know how you do that if you know if
you know me and you've watched me when I
stream sometimes I talk about one of my
favorite games people joke about it at
this point it's it's capablanca Tray
ball game that game if you haven't seen
it you definitely need to check it out
in that game Kappa Blanca ends up having
the pawns place like that exactly as my
v-shape and everything is blocked and
exactly goes that way so he's actually
gaining a lot of space on this side of
the board and then he switches over on
this side because he realizes his
opponent is gonna push so in order to
stop his opponent he actually does
something like that like Chris says on
on YouTube and then he goes H3 G4 G5 and
literally his pawns end up going like
this if you don't know that game
definitely check it out after this class
um you're gonna enjoy it and you're
gonna understand me better for next time
um so that's a nice idea indeed I don't
think it's uh I don't think it's gonna
be in the end like you can't really
utilize that square so I'd rather use
um
H3 H4 maybe H3 G4 is seeing someone else
92 F4 and H4
Knight on this side of the board very
interesting lots of interesting ideas
that I actually hadn't thought about
when I looked at this game
um maybe this is not
I feel though if you do that it's not
that you don't have time you do have
maybe black will also have time to bring
in his Bishop that's basically Black's
worst place piece
when you don't know what to do in a
position you got two things that you can
do in my opinion one of them check your
Pawn structure and look on the side of
the board where you have more space
that is the side of the board where you
probably have to find a way to get in
your pieces to attack
um other thing is look or maybe it's
gonna be three maybe I'll add there'll
be three things
second one look for your worst place
piece and try to find a way to improve
it
and last one
so cliche that I say that it's three
I need to come up with an additional one
by the end of my residency here I will
third one would be look for your
opponent's worst place piece and see if
you can find a way to annoy it even
further
those are things that you can do I'll
come up with a fourth I promise because
I don't want a cliche everyone has three
questions at this point I don't want
three questions I want something extra
well I'm creative enough it will come
don't worry anyways in this position
korbo was like nah I'm gonna go Knight
B5
forget about improving things let me do
this first and I thought it was
interesting in a way because he just
came back with a night from there so
you're thinking well he's not gonna get
to D6 what's even the point of this move
like why
why is he playing it
well to chase the queen away that's for
sure Queen V8 was played by
by uh
uh ponomario and I was like well why
didn't he go there but then
but then you're thinking okay then maybe
we do have time we do have a lot of time
to do whatever we wanted with G3 maybe
G3 is the move or just you know bring
the king there maybe like Chris said
move the Knight
I just don't like Nike one I feel like
it's too passive not necessary to go
there to go F4 something else should be
you know what I would like to go
kingy2h3 G4 you know someone said it in
the chat I think this idea that's what I
would do because we're talking Fighting
Chess let's just be aggressive it's not
our pieces right we can do that
no but seriously that is a good plan
that is a really really wise uh wise
idea for white to open up their bishop
and then
um if black obviously black should not
take in G4 but then we could try to push
and give ourselves a little bit more
space
on the king side if we wanted what I
found interesting is here after Queen B8
E3 was played
so maybe he kept the queen in B8 to
support this move but I always felt that
that pawn was hanging but maybe ponam
Mario somehow thought that that's an
option
so kurbov is like nope not happening
you're not gonna play five I'm
controlling that square very well
and then
um black was like okay now is the time
let me Chase you back you have to play
to Knight E3 and then at least I chased
you back and you don't go to C3 because
you just you just blocked your Square
the thing is white didn't really block
the square there because
um
he actually did something good when you
only have one Bishop left on the board
you want to place your queen on the
opposite color everyone knew this
here yeah good
so that's kind of what he did as well by
by making this move and guess what no he
didn't go to A3 why would he when he can
go to D6
cool stuff here comes the Fighting Chess
that I love why because he's just giving
up a pawn right I mean what 96 thank you
very much for the pawn I'm taking it and
I'm feeling very comfortable about about
this you know I have a pawn up
I have a bad Bishop but no worries I'm
gonna try to find a way to protect this
Pawn maybe it'll be a maybe Rook A7 get
my Bishop out
maybe push some B5 something I'll come
up with something
when you give up a pawn
you don't just give up a pawn like that
can do because you're nice you're never
nice in your opponent you know you you
want to win your games against your
opponent not be nice to them
so this is a really beautiful in my
opinion Pawn sacrifice it's also just
temporary because he's trying to keep
black underdeveloped with those pieces
even if it's gonna take forever for the
bishop to go out he still wants to make
sure the bishop stays there so he played
this move Rook to B6
exactly someone said it in the chat good
um and if I miss some of your comments I
apologize try to make sure I go through
this game because I get very excited and
distracted Rook B6 all right so we're
pinning the Knight but also we have this
kind of idea Bishop takes A6 a very
typical tactical idea four positions
where
uh you know a night on C6 on C3 it
happens very often in Sicilians
sometimes or
in some other maybe even Queen's gambits
can happen sometimes that there's a
knight here in C3 upon in B2 Pawn in B3
and sometimes you suddenly if you're not
careful there's a bishop takes
deflecting your Pawn from there and your
knight is hanging that's the exact same
approach in this position we want to
take and then that night would be
hanging
so Paramore everyone back
as you can see he cannot just develop
the bishop because obviously that pawn
is hanging
and this position is going to be tough
let's just say you are thinking you know
what I'm gonna trade The Rook I'm gonna
trade a pair of Rooks and I'll be fine
well you always have to check to look
for uh checks and captures in fact
recently I've been I've been studying
this um this course
um
unjustable that I like it's called it's
by Judith poger and she has this thing
that's called CCTV and it's checks
captures
oh my goodness I forgot what the other
two stand for this is bad
um check out what CCTV stands for let me
know by the end of this okay Rook takes
z7 checks captures
it sounds like one of those places where
you sell things in the US I think she
didn't think about that when she created
her acronym but um
okay nobody's checking it okay
there's this small little capture so you
sack The Rook for two pieces you and you
basically just you know win two two
pieces for the rook and um
and then this position is gonna be
really variations variations
and one more
one more thing all right
and that's what's happening if you
develop the bishop going back Queen d8
okay
he's so passive he's on the back rank
what are we gonna do well we're gonna
improve some more pieces we're gonna
make sure the bishop stays there we have
the pressure no rush Queen C5 I like
this move
black played Rook F7
and here I think this is one of those
moments like there are two or three
moments in this game that karabov maybe
hasn't played the most
precise way let's say but we're all
human we all want it's hard sometimes to
play without a pawn like we do make the
sacrifice we feel we're good but then
sometimes we're saying okay when is the
moment to get it back
and he kind of went to get the pawn back
right now
threats and variations okay CC checks
capture threats and variations thank you
a couple of people said in the chat for
those of you here not enough
um and uh so you always want to to
consider forcing moves basically the
more forcing the better and threats you
know can be mating thread the next move
or in a couple of moves and
um like serious stuff not just oh I have
a threat to bring the Knight 10 moves
and I get there or something no there
should be a mate threat typically
okay so look F7
so he went for the pawn
but okay now we have the time we're not
in a rush in a big rush he how much time
did he spend here to knock over like two
minutes to play Bishop takes A6 get his
Pawn back and he probably thought that
in case of a recapture of course maybe
he would take back here and
he would be like tripled on the C file
the night would come afterwards to E5 he
would have just you know a great
position
how can we try to improve with why the
position further because black literally
has no moves this bishop cannot be
developed that's hanging
um he doesn't really he doesn't really I
think he doesn't really want to do a
move like this I don't think that that
move would be possible
so he he cannot really escape from this
Queen side what can we do
opening a file might be risky for white
um no why would it be risky because the
king is in D2 the king can always go to
E2 and make sure it stays kind of
protected here protecting f2f F2 is a
pawn that could become weak if you're
going to go G4 G4 is quite typical so we
could open up a file if you want to do
something like this
um but he also might want to play F4
maybe maybe he has one little tiny
little thing that he could do playing F4
I guess but then you would do this
so you would keep it close a4a5 Okay
that's not true
that's interesting
but then if you do that your queen will
be kind of stuck to protect upon
otherwise you'll lose it so I'm not sure
if you want to push the spawn to A5 to
get it to a square where it might be
weak
so try to improve the position like if
you just do this and this and just
improve it and see what he does it's
like what what moves is black going to
come up with the next literally because
literally this move you do nothing you
can even take but you can just do
nothing you can just I think you can
just do this
because if he takes
you take back and again you cannot get
the bishop out he cannot do this because
he's pinned
over here if he goes through A7 then I
think we go Knight here because he
spinned over here
so there are a lot of difficult things
that black is struggling with so white
can just afford to make a few
Improvement moves and only after that
you can take you have the time to do it
because he does not have threats if he
had threats then you wouldn't waste the
time like that
but he went further okay
and in this position he gave black the
opportunity to give a pawn back Play
Bishop D7 give the pawn like another
Pawn like just be like take it if you
want but um white cannot because if you
do then maybe he's finally getting some
activity for that Rook that was stuck
earlier
um
now you really do understand that this
King
could have gotten let's say a little bit
in danger and then
um I think after that maybe there was a
I think there was this move or something
like this that was able to be played
and if you go Rook B5
then we'll probably take it
wait
there might be some Discovery I'm
messing up some something in this line
white has to give up the queen
and get this position
now here we still have ideas with Rook
C8 and try to win try to win the queen
back we have 95 we should have
sufficient compensation for the queen we
have uh a rook and uh and a knight for
the queen and he's still restricted on
the king side but why would we do that
right he was so restricted and in a few
moves you get from this position where
he had nothing to do we could just
improve first even bring our King to G1
if we wanted into that position where we
actually have material disadvantage
so I think Bishop D7 kind of had to be
played and obviously you can't take
another way and if you go back or
something then you know there this Pawn
is still hanging and whether you go Rook
C2 or King E1 the same kind of
the same kind of thing happens he's he's
out
he's just out
black for some reason
Mario for some reason in this position
played Rook C7
um he probably thought that white is
stuck now that he took the pawn in A6 he
probably thought that
um the
the bishop is pinned it won't be able to
move and then the spawn in A2 would be
hanging
foreign
putting extra pressure on the night
because actually you just pinned
yourself
and the thing is that now
a move like Bishop D7 is not exactly the
same as it was before
because
um
because why
because now we can we can do this
and
you you can unlock the bishop because
this Pawn will be hanging if you go like
Bishop there for example
why couldn't you do the same thing
earlier
because you because your Rook was
hanging but now I I want you to see
clearly the difference now there's a
rook there that blocks
so now we can play Queen D6
and black is totally stuck so put on
Mario is a very is very resourceful I
mean he won the World Cup right so he's
very strong player
he came up with this idea of Queen H4
and trying to take advantage of the king
from this other side since he wasn't
able to bring in The Rook that way
so Queen H4 and
um and in this position
you have to make a decision with white
are you going to move the king to E2 and
try to protect
are you going to try to play G3 or will
you retreat with your knight back to D3
so lose the pressure on C6 in order to
protect F2 because clearly that is the
most dangerous Square on the board for
your king and you don't want to let them
and at least according to the engines
uh King King E1 the move that was played
was not optimal for for white in this
position
it's a very natural human move King U2
or King U1 I think King you won probably
a little bit more than King E2 because
you need to you're still staying on this
check so there would still be Queen Rook
takes a to check whereas when where uh
when the king is in E1 and you are
um
like protecting the pawn you're also not
staying so at some point you might be
able to move the bishop without being
worried they take this Pawn with check
but
um it's kind of it's kind of interesting
that um I think the best move that was
suggested was G3 like I don't think I
would ever play this move G3 because
I'm not an engine obviously
but just naturally like just takes and
then that pawn is hanging again so like
what's even the point to give the pawn
H2 unless you're sure that eventually
after you protect it you'll be able to
come back and trap the queen which is a
possibility but
I don't see a follow-up on the H file so
I wouldn't give up the pawn like that I
would rather just go back
and not waste the pawn move and then if
they do take it I feel that we could
utilize this move for something better
unless we don't find anything better
which probably we don't but it just it
just seems kind of strange like I don't
know if I would see Queen H Quinn H5 if
I had seen Queen H4 as an idea for black
I would have never played Knight E5 I
would be scared personally I know about
you guys but I would be personally
scared
anyone here in the audience scared if
you saw Cornish four or not you'd be
fine you'll be like I just got a new one
no you would you would be scared
so-and-so okay maybe it's just me maybe
it's just me okay so he went King he won
so why is this not such a good move well
because here's what's happening most
of the pieces are on the queen side the
only pieces over on the king side are
the queen this night they can come back
and then white has some Pawns so
you can tell yourself that you'll be
fine because in case of anything
is an option
so you can see he has a queen
nobody has ever seen a mate just with
the queen you need a helper
and that is exactly why black
would have been fine in this position if
he found a way to bring a helper to help
his Queen
take advantage of White's lonely King on
the king side
if anyone wants to give it a shot to
come up with the best possible move here
for black if you want clearly I think
you have noticed based on my description
that it's not Queen takes H2 here that's
the move that was played in the game
unfortunately it was a big mistake after
which Black's position just collapses
so does anyone have any idea of what
move black and try to play here in order
to start
um
or to yes starts an attack on White's
King
foreign
on the chart is saying that black is
probably better after Bishop A6 uh I
don't know if better but it certainly
could have escaped from that dangerous
position it was just a little bit too
greedy to get the pawn back for sure
Knight takes E5 no although your idea
might be good if you actually had the
opportunity to go Knight D3
I would give you a thumbs up but
unfortunately you can't because I still
have my Bishop there which wasn't
captured because of this move right but
now we take and you cannot you don't
have a forcing move here and for example
something like this I feel that I could
even take
and maybe maybe not maybe I'm being too
too aggressive I can just go back you
know why why would I worry I want a rook
I can just go back
so I defend someone said it Jay shaper
yes that movers A4 F4
this was the move that black would have
played in this position
so he's trying to open up white skin
because literally the king is kind of
lonely just has the Pawns
and for example like
you know if you're thinking wait a
second I'm just gonna make some trades
and I'll be fine not really because once
this move happens
there are serious threats on your king
and let's just say you're going to
consider I don't know maybe a rook or
queen back to C2
he's just gonna take back
and um pretend like you're just gonna
make the straight
the problem is there's a pawn here in
your territory that's going to capture
here anytime
he just needs to make sure that he
doesn't lose anything on that side of
the board he's gonna take if you capture
back there's this idea or this idea and
suddenly White's King that was safe
before around here because there's no
file opened or nothing now he's not safe
anymore
so F4 and now white has to make a few
defensive moves like like I said Knight
F3 their natural backwards move but you
need to defend your king a little bit
and um okay if black goes back he goes
back okay fine then maybe we retreat
with the bishop too or something like
this so that in case of a trade
recapture back they were saying defended
there
but I think white eater is gonna try to
repeat the position by going back and
forth if it even works
I'm not even sure if if it works
I don't know if
we should be safe here but it's just
it's very it's very difficult it is very
very difficult for white
but luckily for him
ponomariev went for Queen takes H2 he
went for a pawn now don't get me wrong
I'm really a huge fan of I was a huge
fan of
um Victor korginoi who is taking pretty
much all the pawns even poisonous ones
however you have to be very careful and
be very sharp tactically when you make
these kinds of decisions
this queen is now out of play and it's
not coordinated with any other piece to
actually take advantage of White's King
the best it has is maybe a check here or
there the king will go to E2 and then
that's it
that's it for black what about for us
well how do we consider things right now
this move is so human yes this move was
very human but it was also not the best
way definitely not very good now white
only has one way to win here which core
above
didn't miss the chance to see
um
and now and now we have to look at this
King
and the back Rank and then this hanging
piece
and that's how you come up with the best
move
so what is it
back crank Rook hanging
King week
forcing moves remember Judy Polgar CCTV
checks captures
threats and variations we got it we got
it
if we learn something this lesson is
that Sabina forgets what she's learning
but then people are helping her get it
back and then everyone else learns
that's that's the right thing that's the
right thing to do
uh nobody has any idea here maybe in the
club
Ben I'm gonna make you answer
Ed
oh you are a good answer
forcing move with attack
silence that silence
you guys can do it
no it's not a capture
it's a very simple move
it's a threat is a threat
yeah it is it's for it's it's attacking
yeah Queen D6 it's a threat
so it's one of those four right
so it's a threat you're bringing your
queen closer to the attack and and then
you can combine it with Ben's idea which
was Rook takes C6 and then he's trying
to get rid of the defender of the back
rank so he can mate
uh-huh
oh yes that's exactly what black did
yeah check right that's what you're
saying yeah yeah and taking the Rook yes
but but now well first of all we could
take the Rook back if we wanted but but
we're not going to take the Rook back we
want to make this King because the back
rank
so what do we do now
if we're not going to take the Rook and
we want to mate here
no the night
if we take the Rook we don't have we do
have a kind of a serious threat here and
and there that's right but I think I
think tactically that's going to be a
did you see it
this guy discover check yeah so
backwards kind of idea for for the queen
and then that's uh that's an issue so
we're not taking the queen we're taking
the Knight
the capture and then we want to mate we
also attack the queen of course and the
problem is okay first of all we see we
he cannot recapture because of mint
um so he's going to give a check to
escape with his Queen from the attack
and then we go king of three
what's our threat we still want to take
the Rook but more importantly we want to
checkmate
and then
um ponomario is like in huge trouble now
if he plays Bishop D7 then we can just
take the rook and then this is hanging
and like I said you see that Queen
entered but it didn't take the right
pawns and it didn't have support and
because of that
there was just two checks and that was
it
so Black's King remained weak
so I liked kind of in a way how although
he lost some of his Advantage by going
to get back his Pawn he ended up just
um coming back into the game because
black was a little bit greedy by
capturing this Pawn I would say and it's
kind of a little bit surprising to me
because they did have a lot of time
both of them seem to have had a lot of
time is if the times that literature
show us are correct and then Rook C7 he
didn't even take the Rook like there's
no point to take the Rook when you can
make this move and try to distract him
so he can mate him now
um but yeah so so this move was played
and then I don't know if this move was
played or he resigned and and this was
played but anyways this is this is the
final thing that we had and
um
and this is how core above won
this game how did you guys what did you
guys think about it did you like it
I really liked I really liked the game I
thought you know there were some
important points that that were made and
both players really respected the
principles just at some point due to
them some tiny little inaccuracy this
move was trying to attract C5 but then
the C5 proved to be really
um really good for white in the end
because it just kind of gave them the
the power to push to push over the pawns
on the on the queen side and and get
more more space and everything
and um
and then my my favorite thing I think my
favorite move of the game although it's
not brilliant or anything do you guys
know what it is
I'm gonna get to it
you must know
the unexpected King takes
he took with the King he kept his Knight
here so the Knight could go in the
center and then
um you know although the King was there
struggling a little bit but he always
had the opportunity to go back if he
wanted this week he developed a little
bit faster there was no A5 he always
stopped his opponent and yeah he made a
small inaccuracy but I think overall it
was like a really beautiful beautifully
played game and sometimes you got to be
lucky as well for your opponent to make
a blunder to win but anyways that's all
from me today it was it was great being
here I hope you guys enjoyed it we'll
have more things going on uh tomorrow I
think I'm doing I'm analyzing games I
believe that's
um what I'm doing I'm also streaming on
on sandwiches club's twitch page so I
hope to see you there and
yeah I hope you're all having a
wonderful night
and I'll be seeing you very soon
bye everyone